we begin  by hearing an old wise sounding voice  when we see a quiet peaceful setting  this will make our game seem big and  important  now something must break the serenity  will this creature be in the game  now say goodbye to it forever  suddenly and for no reason people  running these pointless slow motion  shots  make everything seem cool and should  bolster pre-sale numbers  that war sound can mean only one thing  we must gaze over an epic shot of a  world  and there should be lens flares  now we see our hero  but only they're silhouette because the  developers haven't finished the design  or finished the story or finished any  gameplay  that's actually ready to show in fact  the only thing they have finished  is the title  [Music]  you